en el vídeo pasado hicimos un montón de
cosas para encontrar una forma de
invertir matrices invertibles pero no
vimos ningún ejemplo de cómo se aplicaba
este método entonces pues en este vídeo
lo que vamos a hacer es tal cual tomar
la misma matriz del vídeo pasado que es
esta matriz la matriz a que nosotros ya
sabemos que su forma escalonada reducida
por filas es la matriz identidad y eso
lo que significa es que esta matriz es
invertible y vamos a tomar esta matriz y
le vamos a aplicar el método que
encontramos en el vídeo pasado para
encontrar la inversa que entonces
siguiendo el método desarrollado en el
vídeo pasado lo primero que tenemos que
hacer es reescribir esta matriz pero
aumentar esta matriz con la matriz
identidad ok entonces
esta es la matriz y ahora la aumentamos
conoce una rayita por acá y ponemos de
este lado la matriz identidad y la
matriz identidad es tal cual
y lo que vamos a hacer es transformar
esta matriz hasta que nos quede la
identidad aplicándole exactamente las
mismas operaciones filas a esta matriz
identidad
ok como lo único que vamos a usar son
operaciones de fila entonces si pensamos
que se le aplicamos a toda la fila no
vamos a tener ningún problema todo lo
que le apliquemos a la matriz
se lo vamos a estar aplicando a la
matriz identidad y porque funciona esto
pues como vimos en el vídeo pasado cada
que hacemos una operación de fila
podemos pensar que estamos multiplicando
a la matriz a por otras matrices que son
las matrices asociadas con estas
transformaciones que son las operaciones
de fila y entonces si le aplicamos todas
las operaciones fila a la matriz a como
para que nos quede la identidad gay eso
es equivalente a multiplicar a por todas
ustedes
entonces toda esta multiplicación de
matrices es la matriz a inversa porque
la matriz a inversa es la única que
multiplicándose por a nos da la
identidad bueno y entonces si le hacemos
todas las operaciones fila que le
hacemos a la matriz se se las hacemos en
la matriz identidad entonces vamos a
estar multiplicando la matriz identidad
por todas estas matrices entonces lo que
nos va a quedar es nada más la inversa
bueno entonces reduzcamos esta matriz en
la matriz identidad pongamos la en su
forma escalonada reducida por filas y
bueno lo primero que queremos hacer es
que todas las entradas debajo de este 1
sean 0 aunque hay queremos poner un 0
aquí y 10 aquí por lo cual vamos a dejar
la primera fila en su lugar
y para hacer que esta entrada se vuelva
a cero lo que vamos hacer es reemplazar
la segunda fila por la segunda fila nada
la primera fila aunque hay entonces
menos 1 más 1 0
2 más menos 1 1
3 - 1 2
0 1 1 1 0 1 0 0 0
y ahora vamos a hacer que esta entrada
se vuelva a cero por lo cual vamos a
sustituir esta tercera fila por la
tercera fila menos la primera fila
aunque hay entonces uno menos 10 que es
lo que queríamos
1 - menos 1 o sea uno más 124 menos
menos uno o sea cuatro más unos 50 menos
1 - 1
0 - 0 0 1 - 0 1 muy bien y como ahora
tenemos aquí este 1 que está perfecto
ahí lo que vamos a hacer es dejar esta
fila tal cual como está y hacer que
estas dos entradas se vuelvan 0
entonces dejan la segunda fila en su
lugar
a la primera fila la sustituimos por la
primera fila más la segunda fila
entonces 10 eso es un 1 menos uno más
uno esto es 0 - 1 más 2 3 1 1 1 2 0 1 1
y 0 0 0 y ahora vamos con la tercera
fila a la tercera fila si nosotros
queremos un 0 por acá tenemos que
restarle dos veces este 1 o sea que a la
tercera fila la vamos a sustituir por la
tercera fila menos 2 veces la segunda
fila ok
0 - 2 por 0 esto es 0
2 - 2 x 1 2 2 0
5 - 2 por 25 menos cuatro eso es un 1
menos uno menos dos por uno o sea menos
1 - 2 - 3
0 - 2 x 1 eso es menos 2 y uno menos 2
por 0 o sea 1
y aquí en esta parte de la matriz a esta
entrada ya está tal cual como la
queremos o sea ya es justo el renglón de
la matriz identidad que estamos buscando
pero nos falta hacer que estos dos
renglones de la matriz identidad sean
como la matriz identidad ósea nos falta
poner aquí un cero y aquí otro cero
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es dejar
el tercer renglón completito tal cual
como está y a la segunda fila la vamos a
sustituir por la segunda fila menos dos
veces la tercera fila y la primera fila
la vamos a sustituir por la primera fila
menos la tercera fila
entonces dejamos la tercera fila tal
cual como está y sustituimos la segunda
fila por la segunda fila menos dos veces
la tercera fila
0 - 2 por 0 0 1 - 2 por 0 0
2 - 2 por 1 c ok
aquí me equivoqué a ver uno menos 2 por
0 es 10 ok entonces uno menos dos por
cero eso es un 1 y 2 menos dos por uno
eso es un cero ahora si uno menos dos
por menos 3
eso es como uno más menos 2 por menos 3
sea uno más 6 entonces aquí va un 7 y
aquí tenemos uno más menos 2 por menos 2
o sea 4 entonces uno más 450 menos 2 por
22 y ya nada más nos falta a la primera
fila sustituirla por la primera fila
menos una vez la tercera fila ok
1 - 0 es un 10 menos 001 menos 102 -
menos 3 o sea 2 + 3g son 51 menos -2
estos son tres
0 - 1 es menos 1 ok y esto de acá es la
forma escalonada reducida x files de la
matriz a ok esta matriz que es la matriz
identidad entonces tomamos la matriz a y
le hicimos un montón de cosas un montón
de pasos de tal forma que la convertimos
en la matriz identidad y además
aplicamos todas esas transformaciones a
la matriz identidad y de eso lo que nos
quedó es esta matriz acá entonces esta
matriz de acá es la matriz a inversa y
listo está súper sencillo no sea la
verdad fue súper fácil hacer todas estas
cosas bueno espero que sea útil